je vous avais demandé un petit peu à
tous ici de préparer une chanson de noël
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez mais
oui il enregistrait mariah carey une
centaine louis oui vous aviez un coach
vocal mais rien n'était sûr on était si
vous voulez jamais dire si vous nous
rejoignez ça fait plusieurs étés c'était
il ya trois semaines je réponds
enregistré une chanson et ils savent à
un coach vocal un petit peu particulier
qui avait une odeur dans la bouche sur
la tête de ma mère et il voulait
absolument alors par les prêts ils
savaient que vous saviez pas que c'est
une caméra cachée à nous mais non
c'était nous n'auront servi à rien et
tout le monde me jurez commun et bien
regardez il y en a un qui est grave
vénère je vous dis ça fays peta c'est
benjamin castaldi
regardez c'est l'artt là on prenait
renault
bonjour j'ai été enchantée je vais te
coûter un peu ouais bah oui et tu étais
un intérêt sur une grosse merde donc tu
sais que sa part du ventre d'accord je
te demander de mettre la main sur son
ventre
donc tu as inspire
je le sens bien tu vois
question
jusqu'à quelques minutes à faire
atterrir à détroit faire des photos
qu'on oui mais c'est une émotion que le
tueur ça me fait refuser ces trucs là de
quoi ça me fait refuser ces trucs là ça
vous sera testée faisait bat péter pitt
et oui d'accord mais tout ça funakoshi
désolé mais mais je pense que tu est
menacée par un pardon c'est peut-être
moi qui te ma présence qui te dérange
mais non pas du tout mais c'était
impressionner ou quoi ou je ne sais pas
vu une large s'est pas vu à la télé
c'est toi qui est désagréable le bon
coaching vocal chebli ok on a fait un
petit vocalises sur coucou faire sien où
et avec 1 h aspiré coup vous
où jouer
bonjour
pour vous
je veux sentir ton air qui vient vers
mon visage ou tu sembles bien coup un
petit exercice de diction vite fait
d'accord tout simplement tu dis nous ne
tiendrons pas monotone
nous ne tentons en arrachent nous ne
nous dans l'autre montrent toutefois se
moquer c'est à nous de nous
désolidarisons pas nous désunir et
toujours évident mais c'est pas si
normalement mais nous ne nous décelons
des roses j'envie parkway vas-y encore
me nous devenons des seuls adhérents
soit pas ok c'est bon mais en tendance
assure qu'elle a coaché qui avant comme
vos stars
zaz par exemple madame star tu exagères
non non si mal et internationale ça ok
aussi des chances et gilles verdez le
prochain c'est gilles verdez que gilles
verdez m
l'anchois avec un peu de choix un peu
d'oignons bien cru bonjour j marc est
prêt à coopérer
vraiment donc je mets juste m'asseoir
etienne pour vérifier que tu prends bien
l'air par le feu
d'accord allez on reprend d'accord
fermin inspiré mais ça va aller ça va ça
va ça va très sensible aux odeurs tout
ça ouais c'est vrai que quand je suis
rentré dans le studio de ces noms c'est
vrai que j'ai senti une odeur
toi aussi tu en fais comme moi je te
remercie donc on va faire 1 h aspiré
devant le au cou on peut avoir un petit
café où l'on n'a pas envie d'un café ou
un truc non ce que vous lui y'a pas une
salle de bains un machin comme sawan on
ne peut pas se laver les dents ou un
truc comme ça non non j'ai l'impression
que tu as envie de me dire quelque chose
mais que tu es nul tu n'oses pas mais il
parle par le moment en fait tu pue de la
gueule
c'est vrai un peu dur est ce que ça
donnera tout cas vous diront pas
honnêtement si chaud mais c'est pas
grave
s'approchant attendait six mois après on
ferme tout comme ça c'est bizarre quoi
tu préfères tu de la gueule c'est à dire
que personne ne liez assez mal et non
j'ai pas peur sont maintenant vides un
truc et je suis pas très bien du tout du
tout et c'est ce qui me rend mon temps
ce mercato
myst faut arrêter de manger des mois des
choses qui plus parce que franchement
votre haleine
là ça me dérange tout à l'heure j'ai
rien dit mais vous avez fait exploser de
la youth et une caméra cachée et donc
souffler encore dans la bouche comme ça
je vous jure
vous allez repartir d'où vous venez
alors
des tests live donc vous sortez de la
pièce puisque vous plus de la gueule
merci beaucoup merci évite à moi je
m'énerve
alors j'ai pas lu est ce que l'odeur
était folle supportable woods a vraiment
failli et vous fait mal et au locker
direct ah ouais tu infernal comader z
n'étiez pas bien du tout avoir non mais
c'est insupportable le gars est bon si
tu perds mon latin julien on peut
l'applaudir julia kempe la ville avec
succès